Next a new study confirms something we already know.
America loves road trips.
Oh, please, yes!
Ugh, again, this is another story
I can get really behind.
People reports a new survey of 2000 drivers
found 76% of them would pick driving over flying
if they knew the drive would be enjoyable.
And 74% said the journey is more important
than the destination.
And 78% said that they found hidden gems
along the way that they would've never found otherwise.
And more than half said that the perfect road trip buddy
is their partner, that's fortunate.
And a lot of people also in this survey said
that a spontaneous road trip
can be equally if not more enjoyable
than a planned road trip, Ross thoughts?
Well, okay. I wanna be very clear.
I find driving in traffic to be outrageous.
I get stressed out about it.
That being said, I love to dilly and I love to dally.
And so, if we can go on a road trip
and just take our time and explore, sign me up.
Other thing I love about road trips
I thought a lot about this, snacks.
Can we talk about road trip snacks
(audience cheers)
Beef jerky.
Beef jerky!
Gimme a big gulp
which I know means we're gonna stop a few times
but I don't care.
I want that big gulp.
I actually have some pictures
of how enthusiastic I am about road trips.
So I'm an RV enthusiast
and this is me when I'm 19 years old,
starting my RV journey.
Yep, that's me and my dog Templeton.
He's long gone.
And that's Nan doing the windshield
because you hit a lot of bugs along the way.
And anyone who can do RVing,
I highly suggest like a classy license, like a Tioga style.
There's two beds, a little table.
You don't have to have a special driver's license for it.
And you just take a map and flip coins at intersections.
Should we go right or left?
I don't know, flip the coin.
It's the greatest thing on earth to do.
And I couldn't recommend it more.
Yeah, Wellie and I,
I actually pitched to him
'cause my fantasy used to go to Winnebago through Montana.
Yes!
And so he said, "What do you think for the honeymoon?"
And we are going to go to Mexico.
Oh (laughs) well, something for everybody.
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪